do you think there's no possibility for
alien life in the universe have you ever
heard of the Drake equation yes yeah so
the Drake equation is essentially a
parameterization of our of our ignorance
about certain things in the in the
universe and we've kind of checked off
seven of the terms and the eight terms
of the Drake equation thanks to new
technology thanks to new telescopes how
many stars have planets around them how
many total but there's a couple terms in
there the lifetime of a civilization and
a certain fraction of how much that
Civilization can dedicate its energy or
what have you towards broadcasting its
presence right so for us to know that
they exist they have to exist they have
to made technology for us for them to
exist and when they have to exist in the
first place so how many of such objects
are that's what the Drake equations uh
really parameterizing now I propose that
you should be able to do the following
thing if there's life in the universe
just life slime mold I don't care what
it is you should be able to set limits
on it in the following sense and and I'm
what I'm going to do is do a rucu ad
absurdum I'm going to prove I'm going to
motivate hopefully I can't prove but I'm
going to motivate the the logic or of of
suspecting that they're extraterrestrial
intelligent civilization okay here it
goes I told let me just tell you um my
colleagues discovered that there's a
planet and it's around a star that's
just like our sun and it's next to
another planet and that planet's full of
life and the other planet's almost
identical to that planet it's it's
almost the same size it has a day the
same age the same length as the day of
the planet that has just rotten with
life it's crawling with Kardashians and
slime molds and whatever right okay so
it's out there just like us yeah I said
to you Joe what do you think the odds
are that those two neighboring planets
that there's no reason physically they
shouldn't both be identical what are the
odds that the other one should not have
life what would you say with the same
environment the same uh solar system
some environment same properties rocky
planet had liquid water it has an
atmosphere it has a magnetic field you
know has all sorts of things I think it
would be more likely that it would have
life very likely it would be extremely
likely okay now let me tell you that
that planet exists it's called Mars and
I brought you a piece of it here okay
this is a fragment okay so this goes in
order of expense okay so this um this I
give these things I give away that big
meteorite is a present for you than um
this is a piece of Mars This I only give
to you I don't have one for Jamie that's
an actual piece of Mars that's an actual
piece of Mars so from an asteroid so
what happened was uh the Earth gets hit
by meteors right all the time and uh but
so did all the other planets Sometimes
some of that material from Mars gets
impact imagine something that big that
Jamie showed before slamming into it's
going to eject it from the surface of
Mars that's going to orbit in the Clouds
of Mars eventually going to get outside
the atmosphere of Mars that the impact
is great enough carrying some of the
debris the surface the crust of Mars and
Etc and that will then percolate
throughout the solar system for tens of
millions of years perhaps until the
Earth smashes into it and it lands in
this case it land in afca that was
recovered from Africa um that little
third of a gram is a slice off a bigger
chunk okay um and not only does that
piece of Mars doesn't have any signature
of life on it and we've been to Mars
we've stuck probes into Mars we have a
helicopter freaking helicopter flying
around on Mars right now it's insane um
we don't see anything now that doesn't
mean that life didn't exist there before
it doesn't mean that if we don't fly
into a lava cave there won't be but it
does it not say something this is called
panspermia something that sounds dirty
but it's no I know the term yeah so so
we exchang material and actually sir
Fred ho the guy who came up with the
idea for the name the Big Bang uh he
actually believed in the steady state
model he believed that's how life was
Seated on Earth the fact is that we've
been exchanging material for literally
billions of years from when the Earth
was you know just bacteria and Mars was
flowing with water we know Mars was was
rich with now the fact that we don't see
any is that proof it never had absolute
and not but I'm just saying it's a piece
of evidence and that evidence is very
hard to come by right it's hard to prove
a negative right it's hard to say that
like Mars definitely never had life can
I stop you there yeah how much detection
do we have I mean how much technology is
currently on Mars that's looking at
Signs of Life they've been probes since
you know Vikings and and so forth how
many of them are capable of detecting
signs of life other than like physical
all of them have had some capability for
precursors to life in other words some
have been able to detect water some have
had spectrometers that could detect
gases how many of them are landed uh
probably 15 or 20 and Mars is what is it
how much smaller than Earth it's about
it's little yeah it's a little bigger
than the moon but a a lot smaller than
it seems like a lot of space that we
didn't detect things on or didn't even
right but but isn't that the converse of
the usual argument that I hear there's
there's 100 billion stars in the Milky
Way um many of them are like the sun
there's 100 billion galaxies or more
like the Milky Way so it's 100 billion
squared the universe is 13.8 billion
years old so what are the odds so
usually astronomers will say will do
calculations uh a following way instead
of like asking what's the probability of
of that um you know for example I've
I've been to Antarctica twice I've been
the South Pole which is you would just
be bored out of your mind probably cuz
all it is is like going out into the
middle of the Pacific Ocean and freezing
it there's nothing to do there the coast
of Antartica is really cool so this is a
rock from there they have like volcanoes
there that's not for you but that one I
got to take back because that cost me
$50,000 that cost you the taxpayer
$50,000 but this you can keep this is
from the south Pole's gift shop Joe
that's a patch in the United States we
have such cool freaking scientists man
our country in the world um I just I I
heard something I was like I wonder if
Joe knows this um it's totally random
but just look how cool is freaking SS
it's pretty cool do you know they can
measure I'll get back to your question
in just a second they measure like the
stress levels of whales and they can use
the stress of whales to determine if
like the Soviets are or Russians are
testing bombs under under the ocean
floor like what the hell I heard this
talk recently this woman studying whale
ear wax so whales don't have ears like
our that stick out that would not be
good for like swimming around right
there's a lot of friction but they have
like these vestigial things because they
like evolve from wolves like I always
thought like stuff came out of the water
and that whales evolved into wolv no no
they think that wolves turned into
whales really yes wolves yes I don't
know this Jamie has cuz I am a total
ignoramus but this is a going theory
that whales evolved from wol so like
most mammals they have ears those ears
have been covered over and what happens
to a whale is that it retains ear wax
and the ear there's ear wax in the whale
the whale doesn't hear with its ears it
hears through its Jawbone uh and that
reverberates and that's how it sends its
sound it still has vestigial ear wax
they sample the ear wax of dead whales
and they can measure how much cortisol a
stress hormone is in the whale and they
know the migratory patterns of the
whale science and they do some of this
research in Antartica so anyway that's
really fascinating we're kind of getting
off topic I want to understand how you
can look at all of the variables that
are possible in terms of the composition
of planets in terms of temperature in in
terms of also different kinds of
environments for life that we haven't
encountered yet but could be real
different kinds of life things that are
very very alien to what we perceive of
as carbon-based life forms